منتدى الصحافه
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج
منتدى الصحافه الذي تتابعونه على قناه
فرانس 24
بعد سنه من بدء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا ما
هي الخسائر البشريه والماديه التي تكبدها
الاعلام جراء هذه الحرب ما هي انعكاسات
النزاع على اداء الاعلامي في روسيا
واوكرانيا هل يحاسب مرتكب الانتهاكات بحق
الصحفيين من كسب المعركه الاعلاميه في هذه
المواجهه للاجابه عن هذه الاسئله وغيرها
يسعدني ان نستضيف هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
الصحفي احمد الشيخ والصحفي نبيل شوفان
ومعنا من لندن الصحفيه منى اللطفى اهلا
وسهلا بكم جميعا
لكن دعونا قبل ان نبدا النقاش والتعليقات
حول الخسائر التي تكبدها الاعلام
والاعلاميون في هذه المواجهه باثناء السنه
الاولى منها ان ننظر الى بعض الارقام التي
وردت في تقرير صدر حديثا عن منظمه مراسل
بلا حدود ضحايا الحرب من الاعلاميين
ثمانيه صحافيين قتلى 19 صحفيا جريحا حوالي
50 صحفي تعرضوا لاطلاق نارين بينهم 26 كان
استهدافهم متعمده ثم بعد ذلك هناك الهجمات
على المنشات الاعلاميه
لننظر الى الهجمات على المنشات الاعلاميه
16 هجوما على ابراج التلفزيون ضرب هوائيات
تقويه البث التشويش على ارسال التلفزيون
العام الاوكراني السيطره على المؤسسات
المزوده بخدمتي الهاتف والانترنت في
المناطق الاوكرانيه المحتله 42 هجوما
سيبرانيا على وسائل الاعلام بعضها نسب
لقراصنه مرتبطين بالمخابرات الروسيه
اذا ابدا معك احمد هذه الارقام هل تبدو لك
ما الدلاله التي او الدلالات التي يمكن ان
نخرج بها من قراءه لهذه الارقام
اولا اريد ان اشكرك على الدعوه الكريمه
وتحياتي للزميل والاخت منال
قبل ان اجيب على سؤالك اريد ان اشير الى
البرنامج الذي نشارك فيه اليوم منتدى
الصحافه
ومنظمه مراسلون بلا حدود فانتم تقومون منذ
سنوات بجهد كبير في متابعه احوال الصحفيين
في اكثر من بلد في العالم
وتفضحون الانتهاكات التي يتعرض لها
اقول ذلك لان البعض قد يعتقد ان هذه
الحلقه يعني كما لو انها الاولى في مجالها
وتستهدف العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا في الحقيقه هذا استمرار لمسار
هذا البرنامج وانا احييكم واحيي فريق
العمل معك على ما تقومون به بالنسبه لهذه
الارقام اخي الكريم
بحرب في كل الدنيا والحرب خسائرها كبيره
على المدنيين وعلى
معظم حتى على الذي يقوم بالحرب الذي يعتدي
ايضا يتعرض لخسائر كثيره يعني لكن اذا
يعني رصدنا هذه الارقام والعمليات التي
تمت وما فضلت باستعراض ومنذ قليل يوضح لنا
جميعا ان المعتدي في هذه الحرب وهو
غزو روسي معلن وصريح يريد حجم الحقيقه
باختصار شديد لانه استهدف الصحفيين عن عمد
واناس جرحوا وقتلوا اثناء المعارك ضرب كل
وسائل التواصل ومحاصرتها وتشويق الى كل ما
ذكرته يعني ماذا يريدون غير تغييب الحقيقه
وفرض الروايه المضلله التي وصلت الى حد
الخبل يعني عندما يقولون اخ ان الغرب يريد
تدمير الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
من هذا القبيل ولكن نبيل شوفان لماذا يبدو
ان لماذا تبدو هذه الخسائر من جانب واحد
تقريبا بمعنى اننا لا نلمس في التقارير
التي اصدرتها منظمات حقوقيه معنيه بحريات
الاعلام
خسائر لدى الجانب الروسي
هل ذلك يعني قصورا في اوكرانيا ليست لديها
امكانيات مهاجمه مدن في العمق الروسي او
لم تريد ذلك بخلاف روسيا التي استهدفت
عددا كبيرا من المدن بما فيها العاصمه كيف
تحيه لك عبد الله والي الضيف وايضا
للزميله من لندن اعتقد انه اولا هذه
الارقام التي نتحدث عنها اليوم وهذه
الانتهاكات الكبيره تبين ان ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا ليس مجرد عمليه خاصه
العمليه الخاصه لا تؤدي الى اغلاق مئات
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه شلل في
في سلاسل سلاسل تمويل هذه الوسائل الاعلام
اقصد الاعلانات والاشتراكات وهذا النزوح
الكبير للاوكرانيين ترك 217 وسيله اعلام
بدون تمويل وايضا الهجوم او الهجمات
السيبرانيه التي تشنها او التي يشنها
الروس التي تقول الذين تقول مراسلون بلا
حدود انهم مرتبطين بالاستخبارات العسكريه
استهدفت 42 موقعا الكترونيا وايضا بما
فيها شبكات توصل الاجتماعي ثمانيه قتله
خمسين جريح 26 منهم
ولكن هنالك 50 صحابيا استهدفوا 26 منهم
بشكل متعب اذا بسبب عملهم
صحفيين بالاضافه الى الاستهدافات التي
طالت ابراج البث والهوائيات والتشويش على
الاقمار الصناعيه والى اخره هذا كل يؤكد
انه ما يحصل في اوكرانيا هو حرب حقيقيه
وكما قالت تلك الصحفيه
لا نقصف فقط بالصواريخ انما نقصف ايضا
بالمعلومات المضلله وبالتالي اذا عدت الى
سؤالك عبد الله الذي وجهته لي انا اعتقد
بان الاوكرانيون الصحفيين الاوكرانيون
يرون انفسهم في موقع انه لابد لهم من
مواكبه هذه هذا الغزو الذي تشنه روسي على
اراضيهم وبالتالي المخاطره بانفسهم من اجل
نقل
ما يحدث على الارض على عكس روسيا التي
تحاول يعني
خطابها الرسمي اصبح لا يعود فقط الى
الحقبه السوفيتيه بل الى الحقبه
اليوم نعيش يعني حتى حتى وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه وحتى مثلا صحيفه مثل
الصحف المستقله في روسيا كازا التي يتولى
يتولى تحريرها
الحاصل على جائزه نوبل
ترك الشان الاوكراني وامتنع عن تناول شان
الاوكراني لانه تلقى يعني تحذيرات مباشره
وغير مباشره من تناول وبالتالي نتحدث نحن
اليوم امام خطاب رسمي روسي له علاقه
بالذاكره او بالمظلوميه التاريخيه للذاكره
الجمعيه الروسيه المتعلقه بالنعود نبيل
سنتحدثات الحرب يعني اصبح مختصر التحدث عن
انعكاسات الحرب
لذلك انتقل الى لندن والى منى اللطف منال
اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه الارقام استثنائيه ام انه انها في
الاخير
هذه الخسائر متوقعه وعاديه في مسارات
الحرب ومجرياتها في العالم كله
اعتقد انه بسبب انه الغرب منذ الايام
الاولى للحرب قام بتزويد الصحفيين
باوكرانيا والاعلاميين باوكرانيا بالكثير
من المعدات لحمايه الزيت مثل القبعات على
الراس والوقي للرصاص هناك الارقام اقل مما
كان يمكن ان تقوم بكثير بسبب ذلك الدعم
الغربي وتلك الامدادات للحمايه الصحفيين
لكن تكمله لما كنت تقول اولا اي صحفي يسقط
في ميدان التغطيه شيء مودان هذا مسلم لكن
التغطيه عندما تكون غير
كامله هذه هي المعضله لانه تقرير صحفيين
بلا حدود على اهميته لم يذكر اي شيء عما
تم لصحافيين الاوكرانيين والاعلام
الاوكراني الذي لديه وجهه نظر مختلفه من
الحرب الجميع يعرف ان هناك العشرات من
القنوات التلفزيونيه الاوكرانيه التي
اغلقها الرئيسيكي الصحف التي تم اغلاقها
كذلك وصحفينا
منعهم من العمل هذا معروف وفي الجارديان
كانت عندما بدات تضييق الاصوات المخالفه
داخل اوكرانيا الجارديان نشرت اكثر من مره
منتقده ذلك السلوك على اساس انه كيف يمكن
للانسان ان يدعو لحريه الصحافه ويقوم في
نفس الوقت بقمع الوجه المعارض له خاصيه
انه ليس هناك حرب ابيض واسود يعني الحرب
ليست ابيض واسود وليست خير وشر نحن كبار
بما يكفي لكي نعرف انه اي حرب دوليه ليس
هناك خيار واشرار وبالتالي كان ينبغي ان
يكون هناك نوع من الموازنه والعقلانيه
وشيء من الانصاف ايضا للقارئ
للمتلقي العربي والغربي والغربي صحيح منال
سنتطرق الى هذه النقطه التي ذكرتي وهي
واجهه للغايه لكن البعض يقول بانه فيما
يتعلق بقراءه هذه الارقام وعدم وجود ضحايا
لدى الجانب الروسي ان هذا الامر يفسر بكون
الجيش الاوكراني ليس بمقدوره او لم او لم
تكن لديه الاراده
لاستهداف مناطق مكتظه بالسكان او مناطق
يوجد بها اعلاميون كان يستدب مثلا مقرات
محطات التلفزيون كما حصل في اوكرانيا
حينما استهدف الجيش الروسي
بالقصف مقرات للتلفزيون العام في اوكرانيا
بالتالي ان سبب عدم وجود ضحايا من بين
القتلى والجرحى في الجانب الروسي هو ان
الجيش الاوكراني لم يكن بمقدوره ان يستهدف
تلك المنشات ولا ان يزداد الاعلاميين لان
هجماته كانت دفاعيه في اغلبها وحينما كانت
هجوميه كانت تنحصر فقط في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ما رايك في ذلك
بالتاكيد هذا قرار استراتيجي غربي الغرب
عندما بدا يعطي اوكرانيا الكثير من
الاسلحه واسلحه متقدمه جدا ومتطوره كان
احد الشروط الاساسيه على الجيش الاوكراني
عدم استهداف العمق العمق الروسي لانه
استهداف العمق الروسي يفتح العالم لحرب
عالميه ثالثه وبالتالي الجميع يعرف
تعقيدات ومخاطر الاقدام على مثل هذه
الخطوه لكن دعنا لا ننسى ان هناك ايضا
صحفيون داخل روسيا يعانون من القمع
والتضييق لانه نحن في مساحه حرب تثير
الكثير من المشاعر وتثير الكثير من جراح
الماضي وكل طرف يضغط على الصحفيين يعني
روسيا ليست بريئه من الضغط على الصحفيين
في الداخل الروسي تماما على غرارنسكي الذي
قام باغلاق كل القنوات المعارضه لرايه كل
الصحف كل المعارضين السياسيين كل الاحزاب
السياسيه المعارضه باوكرانيا تم اغلاقها
اذا انت حزين فيما يتعلق بحريه الراي
والتعبير في اوكرانيا وفي روسيا ايضا
احمد الشيخ البعض يقول بان
سلاح وحده هو الذي كان
محددا لمصير الكثير من وسائل الاعلام
ومسائل الكثير من الصحابيين وانما الاسبق
هناك اسباب اخرى
جرتها الحرب او تسببت فيها الحرب ومن
بينها الاسباب الاقتصاديه اي ان وقف
التمويل الكثير من وسائل الاعلام
وعدى ونقص الاعلانات
ادى الى ان تغلق عشرات المواقع والصحف
ومحطات الاذاعه والتلفزيون في اوكرانيا
ابوابها نعم هذا نتيجه الحرب يعني مؤكد
الحرب ليست يعني
شيء بسيط يعني تداعياتها وخيمه على الجميع
يعني لكن انا اشعر بقلق الى حد ما من
الحديث على المعتدي والمعتدى عليه بنفس
الدرجه يعني
ثانيا لماذا لم يقع قتلى في الاعلام
الروسي لان الاعلام الروسي غير موجود في
الجيش الروسي هو المعتدي ويفرض روايته على
كل الاعلاميين اما الاعلام الاوكراني هو
على الارض يعني بالمناسبه هناك اعلاميون
اجانب ايضا ماتوا في اوكرانيا حينما كانوا
يغطون وقائع هذه الحرب لم يكن القتل فقط
من بين اوكرانيا هناك
هذا ميدان المعركه هذه ارض المعركه
والاعلام جزء منها وبالتالي عندما ياتي
الهجوم من روسيا يستهدف الجميع اعلام وغير
اعلام لكن العدوان او الهجوم الروسي لم
ياتي ومعه اعلام هو يفرض جيش الروسي يفرد
رويته وبعد الحرب باسبوعين فقط مجلس
الدوما الروسي اصدر قانونا يجرم من يعني
يقدم روايه اخرى للاحداث غير الروايه التي
رسمها الجيش الروسي والارجح
اخذوا هذا من مصر من عبد الفتاح السيسي
عندما الاحداث في سيناء اراد ان يسكت اي
روايه اخرى غير الروايه التي ولكن هذا
القرار ولكن يا استاذ احمد بامكاني احد ان
يقول لك من يعرف التاريخ روسيا والتاريخ
مصر ليقول لك بان روسيا سبقت مصر في
الاستبداد والديكتاتوريه وان الديكتاتوريه
الحزب الشيوعيه خاصه قامت ابتداء من سنه
1917 وان مصر لم تدخل في نطاق الانظمه
السلطويه الا بعد الثوره عماجون 952 ليس
هذا نوع من التباهل من جانبها ان اسخر لكن
اتحدث عن هذا القانون بالتحديد اصدرته مصر
منذ عده سنوات لمنع اي صحفي حتى من دخول
سيناء ومن يجد اعتقد ان بوتين
في هذا المجال من عبد الفتاه الطيور
الطغاه على اشكالهم يقطعون يعني
اذا في النهايه
في النهايه كما قيل ذلك قبل
المشكلته في هذه الضحايا او تفسير الاكبر
لهذه الضحايا هو ان اوكرانيا كلها ميدان
معركه بينما الاراضي الروسيه ليست عمليه
مسرحا لاي قتال الا في حالات نادره جدا
نعم ولكن هناك مثلا المناطق الانفصاليه في
لورانس كوانتس
ممنوع ايضا على الاوكرانيين الذين يؤيدون
الروايه الاوكرانيه او الاوكرانيين الذين
يريدون يعني نقل ما يحصل اليوم في المجتمع
الاوكراني في تلك الاراضي التي يوجد فيها
اقليه تتحدث الروسيه باتا من المستحيل ان
يقوم هؤلاء بعملهم واذا كان العمل الصحفي
في عموم اوكرانيا صعبا فان العمل الصحفي
الحقيقي نتحدث عن عمل الصحفي الحقيقي في
تلك المناطق التي ما تزال اوكرانيا
باعتراف المجتمع الدولي الدولي كله اصبح
مستحيلا بل وقد يؤدي يعني هناك هناك سمعنا
كيف يعني كان هناك اتهامات من مراسلون بلا
حدود للقوات الروسيه بارتكاب اربعين
انتهاك في الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعضها يرقى
الى جرائم حرب كتصفيه
الصحفي الفرنسي
وايضا الصحفي الامريكي وكانت يعني مسرح
الجريمه يوحي بانه هناك ربما تعرضوا
للاستجواب والتعذيب قبل عمليه القتل وحرق
السياره التي كان يستقلانها وبالتالي نحن
نحن امام يعني روايه روسيه
روايه روسيه كما قلت لك سابقا تعود الى
ليس الى الحقبه السوفييتيه بل الى الحقب
الستالينيه لا تتضمن او تقتصر على تلك
المره الثانيه هي هي تحوجيه
ولكن يعني
نعم ولكن كانت يعني من جزء من ولكن
الاكثرها سود سوادا واكثرها بالضبط
وبالتالي صحيح ان يعني الرئيس زيلينسكي
قبل الغزو كان هناك حرب ربما معلومات بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وكان الرئيس رئيس
الاوكراني فولوديمنسكي ربما اغلق بعض
القنوات
المتهمه بانها كانت تخلط الخيوط او لا
تميز بين خيوط نقل الخبر وممارسه الدعايه
ونقل البروباجاندا التي يمررها من اجل
يعني تلك التي التي فقط فقط دقيقه عبد
الله تلك البروباجندا التي تعتبرها
اوكرانيا انها دعايه مضلله تريد العوده
باوكرانيا الى حقبه الات
وهذا وهذا ما يعتبر انه يشكل خطرا على
الامن القومي
لا لا لننتقل لنذهب الاحرار الى منى اللطف
في لندن ونعود اليها منال سمعنا هذا
التفريق الذي ذكره احمد الشيخ بشان
المعتدي والمعتدى عليه وهو وهو جيه من
الجانب الاخلاقي ومن الجانب القانوني ايضا
اي من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي لكن هل
يبرر ذلك للمعتدى عليه وهو اوكرانيا في
هذه الحاله ان تقوم سلطاتها بالتضييق
وانتهاك حقوق الاعلاميين داخل البلد
اولا دعني اعالج النقطه الاولى اولا فكره
المعتدي والمعتدى عليه نحن في الشرق
الاوسط نعرف كثيرا انه بعض الاشياء تبدو
على ما هي غير على غير الحقيقه ودعني اقول
لك انه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ليست
بتلك البساطه يعني لم تبدا في 2022 في
فبراير 22 بدات فيه اربعه سنه 2014 وحتى
قبل ذلك ولها جذور ولها الكثير من
المحطات والمراحل ومتورط فيها كثير من
العاملين بالاداره الامريكيه على راسهم
فيكتوريا
الاستفزاز بوتين لغزو روسيا وانا اذمت
وادين الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا ليس في ذلك
اي نقاش لكن معرفه الدوافع ومعرفه الاسباب
ومعرفه على غيار تماما الغزو الذي قام به
صدام حسين للكويت وكيف تم ولماذا تم وماذا
قالت بلسبي الى صدام حسين
تدريجيا عندما تتكشف الحقيقه ويبدا الشارع
الغربي في معرفه كيف تمت الحرب ولماذا
هناك في بريطانيا بالفعل تملم في شارع
البريطاني من نصف الحقيقه التي تعطى
للمواطن الغربي نحن نعرف نصف الحقيقه انا
اعيش في بريطانيا واقول لك ان المنسترين
ميديا عاده في تلك الحرب وتقدم الى نصف
الحقيقه والنصف الاخر مختفي
الواسعه الانتشار بالتاكيد وهناك
اليوم او عن القناه
الصينيه
معها نوبل للسلام فانا في برلين الاسبوع
الماضيه
في برلين ضد الحرب وكان يقول ان تلك الحرب
مفتعله امريكيه لاعاده خلق نظام الحرب
البارده لخدمه هيمنه امريكا على النظام
الدولي هذا الكلام يقول ايضا مين جون
مارشميلو استاذ السياسه في جامعه شيكاغو
يقول ايضا من ستيفن وولد الاستاذ استاذ
السياسه والعلاقات الدوليه في هارفرد سكول
يقول ايضا الكثير من المفكرين والكتاب في
اليورويجن سنتر في لندن هناك الكثيرين
يكتبون هذا الكلام هذا الكلام لا يظهر في
المنسترين ميديا قبل اسبوع واحد قبل اسبوع
واحد نشر جيرمي عفوا سايمر هرش الصحفي
الامريكي الشهير الذي كان بنيويوركاين نشر
سايمر هرش استقصائي قال فيه انه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه هي من قامت بتفجير
نردستيريم من اجل قطع حبال العلاقات بين
روسيا وبين المانيا اذا انا اقول دعونا
نحترم العقول نحن نحن ما حدث في الحرب
بحرب الخليج الاولى وصدام حسين وسوريا
وقلت اكاذيب والقاعيب اريد احترام الشرع
الغربي مظاهرات التي تحدث في فرنسا وفي
المانيا وفي بريطانيا تكشف انه الكثير
يشعرون انه تلك الحرب بالذات وغطيت بطريقه
غير نزيهه
فلاديمير بوتين ارتكب جريمه بغزو اوكرانيا
لكن هذه ليست في الصوره الكامله هذا فقط
نصف الصوره واضح واضح ولكن
لكي نتقدم قليلا في النقاش من الاثارت
نقطه مهمه وهي ان هو في الاخير الاعلام قد
يكون
لا نتحدث فقط قد ربما من الحري بناء لا
نتحدث عن خسائر الاعلام
فقط ولكن نتحدث عن خساره الاعلام لنفسه في
هذه المعركه بمعنى ان الاعلام خسر نفسه في
كل من اوكرانيا وروسيا على حد سواء خسرت
خسر الاعلام نفسه حينما ادت الحرب الى
اغلاق اخر المنابر الحره داخل روسيا وهي
كانت اصلا منابر قليله اما في اوكرانيا
فقد قضت الحرب على وسائل الاعلام التي
كانت تقدم وجهات نظر اخرى تتعارض مع وجهه
نظر الرسميه وبالمناسبه هذا ورد في تقرير
في تقرير لمراسلون بلا حدود بامكاننا ان
نراه على الشاشه هذه الفقره في اوكرانيا
حضرت السلطات وسائل الاعلام التي تعد
مواليه لموسكو بمرسوم رئاسي وقيد التواصل
وقيد النفاذ الى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
الروسيه
نعم في بلدان اخرى ربما لا تحجب فقط
الوسائل الاعلامي المواليه لعدوان ربما
دخلوا السجن او قتلوا يعني هذا يعتبر في
بلدان اخرى من باب الخيانه العظمى هذا ما
كنت اريد لكن بالنسبه للكلام التي قالته
الاخت العزيزه منال انا اعتقد انها تريد
العوده الى التاريخ لكنها تعود بشكل خاطئ
الى التاريخ وتحدد لحظه زمنيه للصراع وانه
لم يبدا منذ الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا بدا
قبل ذلك وانا اقول لها باختصار شديد ان
هذه الحرب بدات مع انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي ثم تحوله
الى الاتحاد الروسي
واصبحت روسيا تريد وتعلن عن قوميتها
وارثوذكسياتها وان عادت لملامحها ولذها
وعندما ارادت القوميات الاخرى التي كانت
مندمجه في الاتحاد السوفيتي ان تفعل نفس
الشيء رفض الاتحاد الروسي ومارس الذبح
والتقطيل في اكثر من قوميه بدءا من دعمه
للشرب في احداث البوسنه ثم في الشيشان ثم
مع الجهد واليوم مع الاوكران
المسار التاريخي يقول ان هناك امبرياليه
روسيه يعني مجرمه تريد قتل كل القوميات
التي كانت في ظل الاتحاد السوفياتي ولا
تريد لها ان تعيش مثلما تعيش روسيا اليوم
هذه القضيه باختصار يعني فاذا هذه القضيب
الان ارجو منكم جميعا ان نبقى في صلب
الموضوع لا نخرج عن الموضوع كثيرا الموضوع
هو الشقه الاعلامي لا يتحدث عن الجوانب
التاريخيه ولا السياسيه ولا الاستراتيجيه
لهذا النساء وانما نتحدث عن تداعياته على
الاعلام اذا اذا سؤالي الذي
هل خسر الاعلام نفسه في كلا البلدين انا
قلق من الربط بين البلدين في هذه المساله
اولا في روسيا لا يوجد اعلام كان كانت
هناك بعض وسايعلمها القليله التي تتمتع
لحريه يقتل من يجرؤ على ان يقول الحقيقه
يعني اما في اوكرانيا فاذا كانت بلد في
تخيل انت هذا المشهد بلد في حاله حرب
وياتي بعض اجهزه الاعلام في هذا البلد
وتؤيد المعتدي عليها اقل ما يمكن ان يقال
انه لابد ان يكون هناك شيء ما رايك انا
اعتقد انه حتى يعني
شهدت فيه الزميله منال من لندن هذه
الاصوات كالصحفي الذي
يعني حقق في الاستهداف استهداف خط
نوردوستريم وغيره من الاصوات التي تعارض
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا انا اعتقد ان هذه
الحاله الطبيعيه
ولا يوجد مثلها في روسيا اليوم من اليوم
يجرؤ في روسيا على ان ينفي روايه الكرملين
بانه الغرب يريد ان يقضي على روسيا من
اليوم في روسيا يستطيع ان يضع حدا او ان
يتحدث بعقلانيه عن الاسلحه النوويه ونحن
نشاهد القنوات الحكوميه الروسيه تتحدث عن
قصف باريس بانووي ومن اليوم يستطيع في
روسيا ان يقوم بتحقيقات ميدانيه ليصور على
الارض من يقوم بجرائم الحرب كما يفعل
الصحفيون الاوكرانيون اليوم وقد
يقول انها حرب فقط
لو سمحت
اعطيني دقيقه يسجن اليوم 15 عاما من يقول
عن هذه الحرب انها حرب وليست عمليه خاصه
ثم انا اتفق مع
الزميل احمد لانه بما يخص انه لابد من
التفريق اذا كان الاعلام خسر نفسه في
اوكرانيا او في روسيا هناك فرق كبير فرنسا
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كانت قبل ايام
افتتحت في في بوخارست بيت الصحفيين
الاوكرانيين من اجل مساعدتهم واليوم يحتوي
البيت 20 صحفي اوكراني يتدربون ويعودون
الى مناطقهم من اجل تغطيه
اذا نحن في اوكرانيا لكن هناك نقطه لم
يزهرها احد منكم وهي ان هذه القيود
المفروض الان على الاعلامي في روسيا وفي
اوكرانيا على حد سواء تفردها الديمقراطيه
الغربيه حينما تكون في حاله حرب هل سمحت
الول المتحده للصحفيين ان يغطوا حرب
الخليج مثلا دون اي قيد ودون اي تضييق نعم
احمد الشيخ هذا صحيح في حاله الحروب مع
الاسف الشديد ده لا توجد حريات اخي العزيز
هذا حاله دمار وحاله والذي يعتدي يريد ان
يكسب الراي العام ولا يريد حقيقه واحده عن
ضحايا يعني
فالحرب حرب والنتيجه الطبيعيه لاي حرب ان
يتم في لحظات معينه تكميم الافواه ليس هذا
تبريرا لما يحدث لكن وصف للواقع لكن حرب
ولان كل طرفين المتقاتلين يخشى من تسريب
معلومه
هي على معلومات وعلى النتائج وعلى نتائجها
ومع ذلك يختلف الامر من حرب الى حرب دوله
معتديه الى دوله معتديه اخرى يعني دعونا
ننظر هل هل كل ما حصل من انتهاكات وجرائم
في حق الصحفيين هل سيذهب سدن ام ان هنالك
احتمالا لان يساءل ويلاحق المسؤولون عنه
مثلا منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود كان بامكاننا
ان نرى ذلك على الشاشه رفعت تقول انها
رفعت سبعه شكاوى الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه والى المدعي العام الاوكراني بشان
44 انتهاكا ارتكبت على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بحق اكثر من مئه الصحفيين واحد عشر برجا
وبنيه تحتيه اذاعيه والتليفزيونيه منى
لطفي هل هذه الاجراءات التي بداتها مراسل
بلا حدود يمكن ان تفضيه الى نتيجه ملموسه
منال منال عفوا منع اللطف
اهلا وسهلا نعم
اكيد عندما تكون هناك
استخدامها في اي محكمه
لمعاقبه من قاموا بترصد للصحفيين في اثناء
تغطيه عملهم في اي مكان هذا هو الشيء
المنطقي الذي يجب ان يحدث لكن ايضا دعني
اعلق على
نعم
يبدو ان هنالك
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع منال لطفي سنعود
اليها فورا ما يتم ربط الاتصال بها مجددا
اطرح نفس السؤال على احمد الشيخ على نبيل
الشوفان عفوا لانك كنت تتحدث قبل قليل
احمد
نبيها هل تعتقد بان هذه الاجراءات التي
بدات مراسل بلا حدود ستفضيل نتيجه انها
ستظل حبرا على ورق انا لا اعتقد انها
ستبقى حبرا على ورق على الاقل دع العالم
والزملاء الصحفيين حول العالم يشاهدون
ويحكمون يعني من من تلك
المعلومات والتوثيقات التي تقوم بها
مراسلون بلا حدود
بالشراكه مع الصحفيين الاوكرانيين
الموجودين على الارض لانه اليوم اذا ما
اردنا ان ان ننظر ونقول هل هل هل انتصار
هل الانتصار يقتصر على محاسبه من ارتكب
هذه الانتهاكات انا اعتقد انه
النصر هنا له مفهوم اوسع وهو تلك الحرب
حرب المعلومات التي تدور بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا حرب القيم التي يعني يريد
الاوكرانيون تبنيها في سياق شعورهم
بالانتماء اكثر او بشكل اكبر الى القيم
الغربيه الديمقراطيات والحريات والابتعاد
عن
الاستبداد وتلك النزعه النزعه الامبرياليه
وذلك
كل ما هو كل ما هو يمكن استنباطه من هذا
الغزو او الاعتداء الذي قامت به روسيا على
اوكرانيا وبالتالي اعتقد انه هناك مكاسب
حققها الاعلام الاوكراني والغربي بشكل عام
لانه حتى في الغرب اليوم يتذكر او اصبح
الفرنسيون والبريطانيون وحتى الامريكيون
يتذكرون ان لديهم ديمقراطيه لابد من
الحفاظ عليها
ويتذكرون ان هذه المكتسبات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه والانسانيه التي حققوها هناك
دائما تهديدات وهناك دائما من يتعددها
دعنا ننتقل الى منال اللطف لاننا استانفنا
ربط الاتصال معها اذا منال تفضلي باكمال
اجابتك
سيكون الاعلام الغربي في نهايه المطلوب
بالاعتذار عن التغطيه التي
كانت من جانب واحد واضح تماما منال
باختصار شديد ونحن في نهايه هذه الحلقه
ونريد ان نقيم السنه الاولى من الحرب
وانعكاساتها الاعلاميه من كسب هذه المعركه
او من الجانبين الاوكراني والروسي برايك
المعركه الاعلاميه عفوا المعركه الاعلاميه
الجميع حتى الان لم يكسب لم يوجه ضربه
قاضيه بدليل الاداره الامريكيه قررت هذا
الاسبوع تعيين جيمس روبن لكي يتولى
مسؤوليه الخطاب الاعلامي الامريكي للعالم
لانه امريكا لا تقنع احد هناك الجلوبال
ساووس كل الجنوب لا غير مقتنع بحدو بحقق
الحرب وبالتالي من الصعب الحديث عن
منتصرين واضح احمد الشيخ من خسر ومن كسب
المعركه الاعلاميه في السنه الاولى ليس
دفاعا عن الاعلام الغربي لديه عيوب ولكنه
هو الافضل في العالم حتى هذه اللحظه
ثانيا من قصر هو الاعلام الروسي لان من
يحرك الاعلام الروسي جهاز سياسي وعسكري
وصل الى درجه من الحمق والجنون لا تجدها
في اي مكان اخر في العالم
نحن نتحدث عن المكاسب المعنويه المكاسب
على مستوى الصوره
هذه المعركه برايك على مستوى الصوره
الخارجيه
اي ونحن نتحدث طبعا عن روسيا واوكرانيا
يكسب عبد الله والمجتهد يكسب نحن اليوم
امام مئه صحفيين الاوكرانيين الذين خضعوا
لبرامج تدريب هم يعملون بجد هم يعملون
بنشاطهم يتبنون قيم نتبناها نحن في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي اعتقد انه حتى
في الشرق الاوسط هناك حيث التاثير الروسي
هو الاكبر بسبب العاطفه بسبب يعني الكثير
من لا نريد الدخول ولكن مع ذلك حتى في
الشرق الاوسط بدا الاعلام الغربي يصبح
اكثر اقناعا لانه اكثر موضوعيه ولان
الصحفيين اكثر تدريبا لانه الري واكثر
حريه نعم شكرا نذكره بانك اعلامي من اذاعه
الدوليه كما اشكر ايضا الكاتب اشكر ايضا
الكاتب
والكاتبه الصحفيه والمترجم احمد الشيخ
واشكر جزي ل الشكر ضيفتنا من العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن الصحفيه من اللطفى وشكرا
لكل من تبعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج منتدى
الصحافه دمتم بخير والى لقاء اخر